joining us now for reaction are two
people who know a lot about getting
Republicans elected from New York
Edie Rollins who managed Ronald Reagan's
historic loved it 1984 election which
won a whopping forty nine states will
that ever happen again and here in
Washington Corey Lewandowski president
Trump's former campaign manager good
friend of the president's both of you
join us now let's start with you Corey
happy anniversary this is kind of a fun
anniversary night it's like old old gang
week here on the show Gillespie goes
down of course in New Jersey no one
expected Kim gordinho to win but any
lessons last night and this loss for
Republicans you were agreeing with what
my point is I agree with you 100% the
lessons are very clear you can't be a
little bit pregnant you can't decide you
want to engage a little bit and then
take it back and then say you know what
I want the president's robocall but I
don't want him to come and campaign with
me what we know is that the American
people in an overwhelming fashion one
year ago today voted for fundamental and
economic change be brought to Washington
DC and that's why Donald Trump won
thirty states in the election against
Hillary Clinton one year ago and so you
can embrace that and bring change or you
can remain in the status quo and say
well we'll make changes on the margins
and I think what happened in the
Virginia race and to a lesser extent in
the race in New Jersey was that you
didn't have kin dates who are fully
embracing the Trump agenda which is
bringing change to Washington but
President Trump did not win in Virginia
I was with him that last night in
Leesburg Virginia and the cold night
where people waited seven hours to see
him it was an unbelievable crowd
incredible energy but he still couldn't
win in Virginia a year ago tonight so
what lessons from last night's losses
well first of all we make too much of a
deal out of New Jersey and Virginia he's
awfully because of the first first race
after presidential election New Jersey
is now destroyed for the foreseeable
future by Christie's inability to
basically get himself out of his
scandals and and Virginia is not armed
State anymore once was one of the
advantages I have of having the better
politics 50 years which is older than
both of you together
and I think the bottom line here is that
it's changed it used to be a mixed state
it's now Northern Virginia
nominates 122,000 votes were carried
222,000 votes with the advantage in
Northern Virginia which was 20,000 less
than the statewide margin those who were
the bureaucrats those were the the swamp
those are the people that Donald Trump's
trying to change the key thing here is
Republicans gonna get some stuff done
you can't be you can't be for Trump's
programs and not for Trump I saw this
with Ronald Reagan I travel around the
country with Ronald Reagan campaigning
for candidates he endorsed every
candidate that wanted his endorsement
that didn't that wasn't the key to
success the key to success was when a
candidate said elect me I want to go to
Washington I want to support Ronald
Reagan Chuck heck was a perfect example
had no chance whatsoever winning in
Nevada he said send me to Washington I
want to vote every day with Paul Laxalt
I'm gonna basically vote for Ronald
Reagan and he won and my sense today is
these Republicans going to run in many
races across this country you've got to
say the presidents got an agenda it's
the same agenda we support the president
support the president and if you do that
you have a build a base and what on a
majority party where basically we want a
plurality Cory ran a great campaign
Cory's a dear friend of mine and I think
to a certain extent it was a brilliant
campaign we won states we hadn't
expected to win and we hadn't won since
1984 we're still not a majority party we
got to go in the trenches we got to win
we got a past taxes we got a pair fix
the health care system gonna do the
thing that Donald Trump promised and we
haven't done and do you agree I want
both of you to chime in on this
we need happy voters I know that sounds
kind of simplistic but it's not we need
people to be happy in 2018 if they're
ticked off pissed off whatever you want
to call it that means that resistance is
winning we need people to see that
conservative populist policies
renegotiating trade deals cracking down
on crime simplifying taxes cutting back
the bureaucracy is gonna make their
lives better and we need to do something
on health care as well anyone disagree
on that we got a lot of unhappy the
Republicans and the grassroots Cory you
take a stab at that know this the voters
vote when it when the economy is good
and they like the way the direction of
the country is moving then they vote in
favor of keeping the position of the the
party in power and what you have is when
Washington doesn't deliver which they
have not delivered for 30 years people
vote for change and so if the
administration working with Congress
doesn't get tax cuts done they don't
build the wall which they pledged to do
they don't get repeal in place done then
the voters are gonna be angry in 2018
and 2020 and what we'll see is a
revolution moving to the other side
because the Republican Party did not
deliver on the promises that they were
supposed to I want you both to listen to
this this was Lindsey Graham sometimes
not a friend of the president but other
times he seems like he is a kind of a
team player on some issues this is what
he said today our problem is our base is
pretty unenthusiastic we've done some
things with gorsek and regulatory reform
but legislatively we haven't cut taxes
and we hadn't reformed health care and I
think that showed up last night and your
reaction there I mean Lindsey and I
don't agree on everything I think he's
exactly right on that well he couldn't
be more it couldn't be more right you
know equally as important we can't be a
party of haters we have to be a party of
fighters we have to fight and sell our
program we talked earlier about why
can't we communicate we can't
communicate because everything gets in
the way if you're gonna sell taxes the
president has to go out as the big
messenger sell tell appellate people why
it's gonna be better for them yeah I can
do that I mean every week we have a
different distraction every week we
basically and it's not just the tweets
it's everything else the administration
has to decide these are the president's
programs this is what the house is going
to sell this with the Senate's going to
sell and we still don't know what those
things that we still know what the tax
plans are make it clear make it sells on
some people like me miss raising taxes
on some people that's why it's gonna
take some time before we let go the
State Department is filled with swamp
monsters they want to take power back
from Donald Trump they want to thwart
his agenda he has a major personnel
problem on his hands because I hear from
people who are meeting with foreign
leaders foreign leaders are more
supportive of the President's agenda in
some cases than the people at the State
Department they're meeting with that's a
problem and the president does not want
to admit that he with me and I go back a
story just last week that US embassies
overseas have refused to put up the
president's picture because they haven't
been supporting that I mean that's
astonishing to me that the President of
the United States this picture is not
hanging their policies look there's 4152
presidential appointments that he has
the right to go and make go make them
and get the bureaucrats out get the
people who are against your agenda
that's on the entire
administration it was on the transition
team that they weren't prepared on day
one it's on the administration that they
didn't feel those jobs and continues to
be on the team right now that they don't
have the loyal Trump people in place to
move this agenda huge problem ed and
Cory it's great to see a big ignite
thank you so much you